مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم لنا من لاهور حسن
خاور القيادي في حزب الانصاف زعامه عمران
خان
وايضا من اسلام اباد الصحفي والاعلاميه
حسن خان ومن روى البنديه الجنرال اسد
دوراني الرئيس السابق لجهاز الاستخبارات
العسكريه ونبدا اولا مع السيد حسن خبر سيد
حسن ما هي تلك الادله
التي يملكها خان في اتهام ثلاث شخصيات
اشار اليها بانها هي التي خططت
لعمليه الاغتيال
البريد الالكتروني
عن الوزراء كان فيها الكثير من التهديد
كذلك السيد عمران خان كان لديه معلومات عن
اعتداء سوف يتعرض له بموجب القانون
باكستاني
ومن ثم تبدا كل الاجراءات
القضائيه يتم النظر في القضيه وترفع الى
الادعاء ومن ثم الى المحكمه هذا هو
القانون مع ان القانون واضح الشمس ومع ان
همم
يبقى حديثك هذا عن اتهام باي اي دليل هل
من ادله
ما اقوله هو كان لديه بعض المعلومات
حول هذا الموضوع وعن الاشخاص المسؤولين عن
هذه المحاوله ولكن ما احاول قوله هو ان
التحقق او تحقيق في الادله لا يحصل الان
في هذه المرحله يحق لاي شخص ان يواجهتهما
ويعود لي وكاله انفاد القانون وتحقيق ان
تحقيق في القضيه وبعد ذلك ترفع الادله الى
وكاله انفاذ القانون وانا المحققين
واضح بانه مصر على ان هناك ادله لدى عمران
خان بيتورطها هذه الشخصيات الثلاث ما رايه
شكرا انا اعتقد ان هذا الاتهام من قبل
السيد خان
الى رئيس الوزراء وزير الداخليه والى كبار
المسؤولين في الجيش
من قبل السيد خان ومن قبل اعضاء حزبه ولكن
امر رفضه رئيس الوزراء وزير الداخليه
وزير الاعلام وكذلك المتحدث باسم الجيش
الباكستاني ومسؤول علاقات العامه
السبب هو انه كما قال السيد خاور في فنجاب
همم بنجر
هناك حق في التقدم بهذه المعلومات تقرير
المعلومات الاوليه ينقل بكل بساطه الحادثه
التي حصلت ما حصل هو ان رئيس الوزراء
السابق قد تعرض لاعتداء همم اطقن نار عليه
واصيب من قبل شخص تم توقيفه
الوزراء قد تحدث اليوم الى الاعلام ورفض
هذا الاتهامات التي وجهها سيد خانده حتى
انه طلب الماء من المحكمه العليا في
باكستان همم تجمع كافه اعضائها كافه
القضاه من اجل التحقيق ده اكيوزيشن
الى السيد عمران خان لكافه المؤسسات من
الجيش من الاعلام من وجههما الى كل
الجهات وبالتالي طلب رئيسه وزراء من رئيس
المحكمه العليا ان يجمع كافه اعضاء
المحكمه العليا للنظر في هذه الاتهامات
المواجهه ضد رئيس وزراء وزيره الداخليه
دوراني اتهام احد كبار ضباط جهاز
الاستغراب الاستخبارات همم هذا اغضب الجيش
شوف التصريحات الصادره ما تاثير ذلك على
فرص عمران خان في حال ذهب الى المحكمه
ولديه ادله
يشتريك
الحادثه لديها جوانب فضائيه وقانونيه
عن هذا الموضوع
يمكنني ان اتحدث عن المؤسسه العسكريه وسيد
عمران
خان قال قال
ان على الباكستانيين الانخراط في ثوره
سلميه او دمويه
مين يقصده
وانا الحزب يمارس اعضائه طبعا يمارسون
حقوقهم يطالبون بانتخابات حره و ناسها
ولكن اذا حصل اي اعتداء اي حد مثل ما تعرض
له هو حين ذلك
يجب ان تتحمل الحكومه مسؤوليه
طلبا بعدم تخطي القانون
وعدم انتهاك اي مواد قانونيه ولكن هذا لا
يعني انه يمكن
نتحدث عن اعتداء ضد اكبر حزب سياسي في
باكستان
خان
ما هي احتمالات
نجاه هذه الحكومه بعد هذا الصخب الذي اعقب
عمليه محاوله الاغتيال
هو خارج البرلمان والطريقه الوحيد لاسقاط
هذه الحكومه ومن خلال عمليه برلمانيه
يحدث ذلك
ياهو الباكستانيه قد اطلعت بدور اساسي في
هكذا نعم نعم
ضبط وايقاع الحياه السياسيه همم في في
الباكستان اسمح لي يتحول الاخيره ليلى
الرئيس السابق لجهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه
الجنرال الاسد دوراني
يعني من خلال هذه التصريحات همم البلد
الان في وضع مهب الريح كيف يمكن لملمت
الموضوع كيف للجيش ان يتدخل لتهدئه
الاوضاع
كرتون فيديو
قانونيه
واذا تمكنت الحكومه من اداره الموضوع
اذا طلبت الحكومه من الجيش التدخل
وهذا امر يسمح به الدستور من اجل مسك
النظام العام حين ذاك يمكن للجيش ان يلعب
دوره طبعا من الحكومه اذا طلبت الحكومه
تدخل المؤسسه العسكريه
اسلام اباد وكذلك شكرا